crise la commission a en effet présenté
les lignes communes que nous lui avions
demandé pour les prochaines étapes
ces lignes communes mettent en avant la
nécessité d'avoir une approche
progressive et graduelle de commencer en
particulier par les écoles d'avoir
beaucoup de prudence et une évaluation
constante d'avoir une approche
coordonnée sur les frontières en
particulier extérieure de l'union
européenne de mettre en place si c'est
utile
une application numérique pour ce qu'on
appelle le traçage mais sur une base
toujours volontaire respectueuse des
règles européennes et de l'anonymat je
cite à quelques-uns des sujets qui vous
montre que le travail qui est
aujourd'hui celui du gouvernement
français sur la base des annonces que
j'ai pu faire le 13 avril dernier à nos
concitoyens s'inscrit bien dans le cadre
est en cohérence avec ses lignes
communes que nous a donné la commission
européenne aujourd'hui ce qui est à mes
yeux une source de confiance et de
confort car il est important que nous
soyons en ligne avec nos partenaires et
que nous inscrivions dans cette
cohérence européenne
plusieurs autres sujets et initiatives
communes ont aussi été poussé sur
l'afrique où la volonté de tous les
partenaires européens et bien d'avancer
ensemble nous avons vous le savez lancer
une initiative à l'issue du dernier g20
j'ai eu l'occasion de m'entretenir avec
l'union africaine plusieurs chefs d'état
et gouvernement et nous avons signé avec
plusieurs dirigeants africains européens
une initiative en quatre axes pour
l'afrique et celle ci est soutenu
fortement par l'union européenne nous
avons aussi une volonté commune
d'avancer sur les diagnostics et
traitements et vaccins et sur ce sujet
nous avons là aussi engagée depuis
plusieurs semaines un travail en
profondeur avec l'organisation mondiale
de la santé
plusieurs fonds thématique des grandes
organisations et fondations publiques et
privées et nous aurons l'occasion
demain en début d'après-midi avec
l'organisation mondiale de la santé de
lancer cette initiative qu'elle aussi
s'inscrit dans une cohérence européenne
puisque après le lancement de demain
nous aurons le 4 mai prochain la
conférence de financement de cette
initiative qui sera conduite avec la
présidente de la commission européenne
ou soula vanderlei il ya deux autres
sujets que je veux retenir de ce conseil
européen qui sur le plan économique
industriel et financier ont structuré
nos débats la première chose c'est la
souveraineté européenne l'autonomie
stratégique européenne c'est un concept
que la france pousse depuis près de
trois ans vous le savez sur lequel nous
sommes beaucoup engagé qui est déclinée
sur le plan du numérique sur le plan de
l'écologie est aussi notre politique
industrielle
un consensus est en train de se forger à
la lumière de cette crise pour renforcer
l'autonomie stratégique européenne
c'est-à-dire notre souveraineté notre
capacité à réduire notre dépendance à
l'égard du reste du monde
renforcer notre capacité à produire sur
le plan sanitaire
nous l'avons vu avec les matériels de
propres parts dans les matériels de
protection mais aussi beaucoup de ce
dont nous avons besoin dans cette crise
la france s'est organisé pour produire
elle-même plusieurs de ces matériels
l'europe l'a aussi fait et nous devons
aller plus loin plus fort mais sur
beaucoup de secteurs industriels nous
faut renforcer notre autonomie
stratégique
nous avons donc demandé cette analyse à
la commission européenne avec la volonté
de réorganiser nos chaînes de production
pour réduire notre dépendance au reste
du monde c'est important pour l'europe
c'est très important aussi pour la
france
à côté de ce concept et de cet objectif
de souveraineté c'est la notion de
solidarité qui a été largement abordé
cette crise touche très sévèrement
plusieurs pays européens la france en
fait partie mais je veux avoir une
pensée toute particulière pour plusieurs
de nos voisins qui sont encore plus
durement touchés que nous nos voisins
italiens nos voisins espagnols nos
voisins belges tout particulièrement
remercié aussi plusieurs voisins qui ont
été solidaires sur le
sanitaires je pense à l'autriche à
l'allemagne au luxembourg
et pour parler d'un pays non membres de
l'union européenne à la suisse aussi
mais cette crise je le disais à plus
touchés certains pays que d'autres des
plans de relance plutôt des plans de
d'urgence ont été mises en oeuvre dès le
début avec des sommes massives qui ont
été mobilisés nous le savons pour ce qui
est de la france avec des chiffres
vertigineux
c'est vrai de la plupart des pays
européens néanmoins ces réponses sont
asymétriques
car la garantie des états n'est pas la
même dans ce contexte et donc la
garantie qui est apportée par des états
dont la signature est très très préservé
ne sont pas de la même nature pour leur
entreprise que celle qui est apportée
par des étapes plus fragilisés cette
asymétrie elle va continuer à s'aggraver
si nous la corrigeons pas et elle peut
mettre en danger tout à la fois la
cohérence de la zone euro mais aussi
l'unité du marché unique et je crois que
c'est très important ça a été rappelé
avec beaucoup de force par la présidente
de la commission européenne comme par la
présidente de la banque centrale
européenne aujourd'hui face à cette
crise
il nous faut donc être très vigilants à
la solidité l'unité l'union européenne
et prendre en compte que nous allons
pendant plusieurs semaines et plusieurs
mois
avoir une situation qui est encore
difficile où il nous faudra être en
résistance en résilience c'est à dire
aider plusieurs secteurs de notre
économie qui ne pourront pas repartir à
plein certains ne pourront pas repartir
tout de suite d'autres repartiront mais
avec beaucoup de freins encore et nous
savons que ça durera au moins plusieurs
semaines peut-être plusieurs mois et il
nous faudra ensuite bâtir un plan de
relance économique au bon moment
vraisemblablement pas ce printemps mais
au moment où sont en train de sortir du
virus et bien il faudra la relancer
fortement notre économie sur le plan de
sa demande comme de son offre nous
savons que ces plans seront à nouveau
financées
ils devront être massif parce que ce que
nous sommes en train de voir au niveau
de l'union européenne c'est que le choc
que nous
nous sommes en train de subir il est
aujourd'hui tel qu'on le mesure entre 5
à 10 points du pib européen
c'est sans précédent la présidente de la
banque centrale européenne a même dit
que ça pouvait se chiffrer à la fin de
la crise entre 0 et 15 points de pib
européen et donc il nous faut préparer
tout ça est à coup sûr cette réponse ne
peut être laissée aux seuls états même
avec des dérogations et donc compte tenu
d'une part de devoir d'unité de solidité
de l'union européenne et de la zone euro
et d'autre part de la magritte ud de ce
choc
il nous faut une réponse solidaire
organisé est forte
c'est cela ce que nous avons commencé à
discuter ce sur quoi nous avons demandé
à la commission de travailler à la fois
pour en définir les montants tels qu'on
les envisage aujourd'hui les secteurs
prioritaires et les mécanismes la france
défend une position extrêmement claire
en la matière d'une part il nous faut
être à la hauteur de cette réponse
décidée le plus tôt possible les
réponses les plus fortes possibles
nous avons su sur le plan monétaire
répondre dos à nos besoins
il nous faut sur le plan budgétaire
continuer pour les phases à venir celle
de la résistance et celle de la relance
décidées tôt et fort nous faut donc
cette réponse forte qui est à la mesure
de ce que nous voyons aujourd'hui cinq à
dix points de bible ouvre la deuxième
chose c'est qu'il nous faudra une
capacité commune d'endettement pour
financer cette réponse les états n'ont
pas la possibilité de le financer sur la
base de leur contribution
c'est un changement complet des
capacités budgétaires européennes je
vous le rappelle le budget autour d'un
point du bib pnb européen aujourd'hui et
donc qui n'est plus à la bonne taille et
enfin il faudra des transferts
budgétaires réel économique pas
simplement des prêts mais des transferts
vers les régions qui sont les plus
touchés vers les secteurs qui sont les
plus touchés c'est à cette condition que
nous pourrons apporter la bonne réponse
sur le plan économique financier
industriel et en même temps préserver
l'unité
non seulement de la zone euro mais du
marché unique européen ce travail est
donc encore à bâtir plusieurs
instruments sont disputés l'idée d'un
fonds de relance économique
l'idée aussi d'avoir dans le cadre des
perspectives financières
un chapitre qui soient liés à la relance
ce qui compte c'est que ce soit
suffisamment important financé par une
capacité comme une garantie comme une
capacité commune d'endettement et qui
est à la clé des vrais transferts
budgétaires vers les régions et des
secteurs les plus touchés
voilà l'état de nos discussions des
choses ont été réglés je finirai sur ce
point quand on parle de relance
économique et de solidarité je veux m'en
féliciter les ministres de l'économie et
des finances sont d'ores et déjà acté
trois mesures importantes sur ce plan là
qui équivalent à un montant d'environ
500 milliards d'euros
la mesure dite sûre qui est celle de
refinancement par la commission
européenne
des mécanismes de chômage partiel
décidées par les pays une mobilisation
de la banque européenne d'investissement
qui permet des prêts en particulier de
long terme mais de financer par très les
secteurs économiques les plus touchés et
mise en oeuvre du mécanisme européen de
stabilité avec une réponse yoko vide
sans les conditionnalités d'habitude
réservé au msc trois réponses sont
importantes elles doivent être mises en
oeuvre au 1er juin c'est une attente
forte de beaucoup de nos collègues et je
les salue
elles sont néanmoins insuffisante pour
les prochaines étapes d'où la nécessité
d'en cesser débat si vous avez des
questions j'y réponds que si le
président est ce que les européens ont
encore repoussée à plus tard le moment
de vérité dont vous parliez sur sur
l'endettement commun et quels sont les
obstacles qui restent
à franchir pour y arriver alors d'abord
il des choses qui sont consolidées et
sur lesquels des convergences nouvelle
secret sur la souveraineté en
particulier économiques industrielles
stratégiques militaires technologiques
environnementales les choses sont en
train d'avancer fortement et là-dessus
l'europe est au rendez vous de
l'histoire et des accords d expression
d'ailleurs nouvelle inédite se sont fait
jour dans ce conseil et je le vois comme
un signe positif
ensuite je crois que il y à un consensus
sur la nécessité d'une réponse rapide et
d'une réponse forte et là aussi par
rapport à ce qu'on a pu connaître au
moment de la crise financière
il y a dix ans je crois que c'est une
avancée ce qui d'ailleurs a permis à la
banque centrale européenne de réagir
très vite et de manière adaptée
il ya une avancée personne ne conteste
le fait qu'on ait un besoin de réponses
qui est entre 5 et 10 points de notre
pizza il ya un accord il ya aujourd'hui
des désaccords qui demeure c'est tout à
fait vrai sur les mécanismes et en
particulier l'idée que ça puisse être
financé
d'ailleurs c'est pas tendre fera entrer
dans la technique la question d'un
endettement commun c'est plutôt la
question de savoir s'il sert à financer
des prêts des transferts réel je le dis
très sincèrement si c'est que l'europe
s'endettent pour faire des prêts vers
d'autres pays ça n'est pas à la hauteur
de la réponse pourquoi parce que ces
prêts viendront s'ajouter aux dettes que
ces pays ont déjà et les déséquilibres
financiers que vous avez dans les pays
les plus fragiles les plus impactés par
la crise aujourd'hui sanitaires et qui
parfois avaient été les plus impactés
par la crise financière si tu n soul
sera pas réglée ils auront simplement un
prêt de plus pas avec le marché mais
avec le reste de l'europe
ça ne réglera pas le problème de fond
est donc là où nous avons des désaccords
c'est dans la nature des transferts qui
sont faits je crois que dans le mot non
que nous vivons ces transferts doivent
être des transferts par subsides des
vrais transferts budgétaires ou ce soit
ce fonds de relance ou bien notre budget
ayant émis sur le marché avec une
garantie commune et bien pourra
transférer budgétairement vers une
région particulièrement touchée
un secteur particulièrement touché avec
des règles et une gouvernance qui
devront être très clair accepté par tous
mais qui pourra transférer une capacité
à rebondir à reims
là-dessus il n'y a pas de consensus
aujourd'hui est néanmoins c'est une
réponse qui que nous devrons un moment
fournir et je crois de manière très
claire que notre europe n'a pas d'avenir
si vous ne savons pas apporté cette
réponse
et ça n'est pas apporter une réponse
pour telle région simplement ou tel
secteur le marché unique c'est un tout
c'est un bloc et le marché unique
aujourd'hui il profite à certains états
ou certaines régions qui sont les plus
productifs de l'europe parce qu'elles
produisent des biens qu'elles peuvent
vendre vers d'autres régions
si on abandonne ces régions si on laisse
tomber et partie de l'europe
c'est toute l'europe qui tombera parce
que les pays qui bloque sont toujours
ceux qu'on connaît les frigos
l'allemagne les pays bas et ce qu'ils
nous sommes transfert nous sommes dans
la discussion
chacun a ses contraintes politiques
chacun a ses ses certitudes
certains ont fait aussi beaucoup
d'efforts pour avoir la situation
financière qui est la leur et donc je
moi je respecte totalement les positions
qui sont défendues et il ne s'agit pas
d'ailleurs de considérer que tous les
efforts qui ont été avant faire en crise
par les uns et les autres sont réduits à
néant et ça vaut aussi pour la france
on a fait un très gros travail ces
dernières années sur beaucoup de sujets
nous avons une crise il faut y répondre
et ne se pose pas de questions ça
n'enlève rien à ce qu'on a fait avant et
on re bâtir un sur cette base là mais le
caractère exceptionnel de la réponse
économique financière que nous devons
tous apporté sur le col vide fait que la
part de cette réponse doit donner lieu
qu'à une contribution exceptionnelle et
c'est cette part là qu'il faut savoir
mettre en commun et donc ce que je dis à
tous ses états qui parfois disent nous
on a fait beaucoup d'efforts beaucoup de
réformes
vous voulez qu'on aille aider des pays
qui n'ont pas fait ces réformes et qui
sont plus loin de nous c'est bien les
différences continueront d'exister et il
en va de la responsabilité de chacun et
l'idée n'est pas d'effacer tout le passé
mais de dire cette crise n'a rien à voir
avec tout cela nous devons nous tenir
ensemble et ne l'abandonné personne et
elle requiert une capacité pour toutes
les réponses à cette crise des paiements
solides
et donc oui il y a des désaccords et des
états dont la psychologie profonde on
les contraintes politiques justifie des
positions très dures
je crois que tout ça doit se bâtir dans
la discussion et les prochains jours les
prochaines semaines seront très
importants nous avons un nouveau rendez
vous qui se tiendra début mai la
commission va clarifier les propositions
qu'elle veut nous faire nous allons
nous-mêmes travailler sur des formats
multiples c'est à dire en bilatérales
avec plusieurs pays nous retrouver dans
des groupes adaptées pour faire avancer
ce débat mais je le dis avec beaucoup de
force et je le redis l'europe est à un
moment de vérité et nous devons tout
faire pour qu'elle ait une réponse à la
hauteur de son histoire
c'est à dire avec la bonne ambition est
aussi changer des habitudes qui sont
parfois les nôtres parce que ce virus
est un choc exceptionnel pour nos
sociétés pour nos pays
il implique donc une réponse
exceptionnelle merci à vous bon courage
on pourra j'avoue dans cette période
également avec toutes les contraintes
pour exercer le métier je le sais merci
en tout cas continue